foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Azkaban prison this will
include discussions surrounding the
island that it's on when the prison was
introduced who created the prison itself
and where the island actually is
considered by many to be reminiscent of
the depths of Hell Azkaban prison would
be the last place at a witch or wizard
in the Harry Potter Universe would want
to end up in fact the name Azkaban even
backs up this horrific reputation a
Sinister name that was created through
combining Alcatraz a famous muggle
Island prison and Abaddon the Hebrew
word for place of Destruction or depths
of hell but where did this terrible
place come from was the island that
housed Azkaban prison always a magnet
for dark magic before the Fortress was
built what was the island like the truth
is before the dark was it known as a
Christus ever set foot on the island
Azkaban was an island just like any
other when we think of the significant
dark Wizards in Wizarding history a
Christmas isn't necessarily the most
well known but after this video he might
just be the first dark wizard that comes
to mind you see a Christmas was a
practitioner of the worst kinds of dark
arts imaginable very little is known
about to Christus other than the fact
that he was alive during the 15th
century and that he was evil pure evil
no one even knows his nationality but
what we do know is that Acres this was
the first Arc Wizard or maybe even the
first person to ever step foot on the
island that would later support
azkaban's dark Fortress while traveling
in the 15th century akrisdis stumbled
upon the island which at the time had no
infrastructure to speak of however it
wasn't long before Christus made the
island his own little dark arts
experiment placing all sort of charms in
the unclaimed territory one of the first
charms that Christus placed on the
island was a concealment charm
preventing anyone other than him from
intentionally locating it for this
reason Azkaban has never appeared on any
map muggle or magical all we know is
that it's located in the North Sea a
marginal sea of the Atlantic ocean
located between Great Britain Denmark
Norway Germany the Netherlands Belgium
and France this was the beginning of the
Island's turn for the worse after
placing the concealment charms on the
island a Christus began his Twisted dark
arts experiments by luring muggle
Sailors to the island after capturing
them acrisdis would torture and
eventually murder them using whatever
Twisted abilities he had in his magical
Arsenal to ensure maximum suffering and
what did A Christmas need to conduct
these horrific experiments why a
fortress of course not long after his
experiments began a Christus erected a
gigantic dark Fortress terrifying enough
to strike fear into even the most
courageous witches and wizards this
continued for many many years claiming a
vast number of victims eventually after
enough torture and murder aquestus had
completely lost touch with reality the
dark wizard who was hopping mad before
landing on the island had reached an
entirely new level of insanity the
product of constant experimentation with
dark magic it was in his state of
complete Madness that many suspect a
Christus created the first ever
Dementors the aftermath of all of those
tortured Sailors Dementors are among the
foulest creatures that walk this Earth
they infest the darkest filthiest places
the glory and Decay and despair they
drain Peace Hope and happiness out of
the air around them even Muggles filled
their presence though they can't see
them get to nearer dementor and every
good feeling every happy memory will be
sucked out of you if it can the dementor
will feed on you long enough to reduce
you to something like itself soulless
and evil you'll be laughed with nothing
but the worst experiences of your life
it wasn't until many many years later
when the Christus finally died that the
concealment charms on the island faded
away finally revealing the island to
others the giant Island which acrystis
had enlarged simply appeared out of
nowhere which prompted the ministry of
magic at the time to investigate
those who entered to investigate refused
afterwards to talk of what they had
found inside but the least frightening
part of it was that the plagues was
infested with Dementors many in
Authority thought Azkaban an evil place
that was best destroyed others were
afraid of what might happen to the
Dementors infesting the building if they
deprived them of their home the
creatures were already strong and
impossible to kill many feared a
horrible Revenge if they took away a
habitat where they appeared to thrive
the very walls of the building seemed
steeped in misery and pain and the
Dementors were determined to cling to it
expats who had studied buildings built
with and around dark magic contended
that Azkaban might wreak its own Revenge
upon anybody attempting to destroy it
the Fortress was therefore left
abandoned for many years a home to
continually breeding Dementors as
mentioned above after the initial
attempts to survey the island the
decision was made leave the island alone
entirely this decision was driven mainly
out of the fear that anyone attempting
to destroy it would be met with the
Island's Revenge however shortly after
the international statute of Wizarding
secrecy was introduced in 1689 that all
changed upon the signature of the
international statute of secrecy in 1689
Wizards went into hiding for good it was
natural perhaps that they formed their
own small communities within a community
many small villages and hamlets
attracted several magical families who
banded together for Mutual support and
protection the minister for magic at the
time and the second ever official
Minister for magic I might add was
Damocles Raul Rao took over from eulik
gamp and integrated being tough on
Muggles into his election campaign
however in later years Raul did take
things too far eventually being censored
by the international Confederation of
wizards in and being forced to step down
before all of this though it occurred to
Raul that the system for imprisoning
witches and wizards at that time was no
longer going to work primarily due to
concerns surrounding security you see
before Azkaban became the spot for
imprisoning witches and wizards there
were many many different locations that
someone who broke Wizarding law could be
locked up the ministry of magic felt
that the small Wizarding prisons that
existed up and down the country in
various towns and Villages posed a
security risk because attempts by
incarcerated witches and wizards to
break out often led to undesirable bangs
smells and light shows a purpose-built
prison located on some remote hebridian
island was preferred and plans had been
drawn up when Damocles Raul became
Minister for Magic the international
statute of secrecy was introduced in
1689 and Doral didn't take over until
1780 teen this meant that for nearly two
decades prior to round taking over The
Wizarding prison issue had been on their
radar however Raul didn't agree with the
existing plans to create a new
purpose-built prison instead he pushed
and pushed to utilize the existing
infrastructure at Azkaban Raul was an
authoritarian had risen to power on an
anti-muggle agenda capitalizing on the
anger felt by much of the Wizarding
community at being forced to go
underground sadistic by Nature Rouse
grabbed the plans for the new prison at
once and insisted on using Azkaban he
claimed that the Dementors living there
were an advantage they could be
harnessed as guards saving the ministry
time trouble and expense in spite of
opposition from many Wizards among them
experts on both Dementors and buildings
with azkaban's kind of dark history role
carried out his plan and soon a steady
trickle of prisoners had been played
face there none ever emerged if they
were not mad and dangerous before being
placed in Azkaban they swiftly became so
Rel continued in his role for a number
of years before being ousted and was
eventually succeeded by the third ever
Minister for magic Perseus Parkinson who
shared similarly hateful views on
Muggles even going as far as to try and
ban witches and wizards from marrying
Muggles Raul was succeeded by Percy's
Parkinson who was likewise Pro Azkaban
by the time that Eldritch diggery took
over as Minister for Magic the prison
had been operating for 15 years there
had been no breakouts and no breaches of
security the new prison seemed to be
working well it was only when Diggory
went to visit that he realized exactly
what conditions inside were like
prisoners were mostly insane and a
graveyard had been established to
accommodate those that died of despair
by the time Eldritch diggery the only
Minister who may have actually opposed
the use of Azkaban took over it was too
late as Azkaban had proven itself a
competent holding facility however he
did still question the use of Dementors
as prison guards launching a committee
to look into things further back in
London diggery established a committee
to explore alternatives to Azkaban or at
least to remove the Dementors as guards
experts explained to him that the only
reason the Dementors were mostly
confined to the island was that they
were being provided with a constant
supply of souls on which to feed if
deprived of prisoners they were likely
to abandon the prison and head for the
mainland this advice notwithstanding
diggery had been so horrified by what he
had seen inside Azkaban that he pressed
the committee to find Alternatives
before they could reach any decision
however diggery caught Dragon pox and
died Dicker Theory tried his best during
his years as minister to find a
replacement for the Dementors that
inhabited Azkaban but due to his
untimely death the hands of dragonpox
this plan never came to fruition after
Diggory no Minister for magic questioned
the activities of Azkaban for 265 years
with Minister after Minister choosing to
turn a blind eye to the inhumane
conditions inside of the Fortress as
awful as the Fortress was it was
effective as a prison and its existence
meant that the terrifying Dementors
inhabiting the island were accounted for
it wasn't until Kingsley shacklebold
took over in 1998 that things were
Revisited with shacklebolt purging the
prison of dementas to this day Azkaban
prison is still used by the ministry of
magic but it's a lot different than it
used to be gone are the days of
horrifying Dementors patrolling The
Fortress instead the ministry of magic
utilizes auras as Gods who are regularly
rotated from the mainland while it's
certainly no island paradise the walls
of Azkaban are a touchless dismal than
they used to be where before a sentence
in Azkaban could rob you of your
Humanity the new Azkaban just might
offer the right witch or wizard a chance
at Rehabilitation and that's it for this
video did you know about azkaban's rich
history the creation of the Dementors
ecristus if you have any questions leave
them in the comment section below until
next time remember it matters not what
someone is born but what they grow to be
foreign